Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says to the
prophet Sam
as is in the one of the closing verses
of
he says subhanahu wa ta'ala speaking to
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
indeed
we have sent revelation to you,
oh messenger Muhammad,
just as we have sent revelation to Noah
before you and the prophets that
followed.
This verse here
is
one of many evidences
that
was the first messenger to humanity.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says to the
last and final messenger
we have sent revelation to you just as
we have sent revelation to and the
prophets that followed.
So Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala here
mentions
that the prophets that came to humanity
and the messengers that came to humanity
all followed.
In the narration of anis collected by
both bkari and Muslim the prophet
sallall.aii alaihi wasallam tells us
about the day of judgment
that on the day day of judgment humanity
us included you and I all of us we are
going to be in the ma Allah will have
resurrected us from our graves we will
be brought forth and we will be waiting
for Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala's arrival
to judge us
and during that time
many much time will
go by and Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala has
not arrived. The prophet sallallah.aii
wasallam mentions that the sun will be a
mile away from the earth
and that people will be literally
drowning in their sweat.
In one narration, the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam people because of
the heat and anxiety some of them will
have their own sweat
up to their
heads up to their faces to their mouths
in sweat.
And this is all based on a person's
actions.
And that during this time the prophets
and the people
will go start going to the different
messengers
and asking for them to intercede
on their behalf with Allah so that he
will start and commence the day of
judgment.
So the first prophet
that the people will go to is Adam. And
notice how I said the first prophet
because there is a difference between a
prophet and a messenger. Both of them
are sent. The first messenger
to humanity is noisam.
However, Adam
did speak to Allah. Allah did speak to
him. Gibl came to him while he was on
the earth. And this is why when the
prophet Sam
was asked if Adam was a prophet, he
said,
he said yes. He was spoken to by Allah.
One of the easiest ways to distinguish a
prophet and a messenger is that every
messenger is a prophet.
But not every prophet is a messenger.
A messenger is a rung higher than a
prophet.
And so every messenger is by default a
prophet, but not every prophet is a
messenger.
But the first messenger is
as we'll hear in this narration. The
people will go to Adam
and they will say Allah created you with
his two hands and he taught you the
names and you are the forefather of all
of humanity.
Do you not see the turmoil the the the
do you not see the distress that we
are under?
intercede on our behalf with Allah that
he come and judge us and get this day
over with. And so Adam will say to us,
will say to them,
it was my sin that put us in this
position in the first place. I'm not fit
for this. I'm worried about myself right
now.
Rather go to Noi.
And so the people will then go to Noi.
The prophet Muhammad sallallah.aii
wasallam tells us that the people will
arrive at no and they will say you are
the first messenger of Allah to
humanity.
You know, there's posters that many
of us probably grew up with where we
have the tree of the prophets and it has
Adam at the trunk and then it has the
different prophets and their respective
lineage. And usually
right after Adam, between Adam and Noah,
who is usually mentioned? Does anybody
remember?
Adris. Right. This is a very weak
opinion
of the historians and
rather the opinion and is that
is one of the prophets of beni
and that's why he was mentioned with the
prophets of beni is inah and elsewhere
rather
is way later
rather the first messenger is
according to the Quran according to the
sunnah here and its most obvious of
interpretations.
Now what happened to humanity
for them to need a messenger to come to
them and
Ib
the prophet Sam's
cousin
he says that between
and Adam
were 10 generations of human beings
and that all 10 of these generations
were started out upon the worship of
Allah alone without any partners. their
father was Adam.
They couldn't have learned or been
taught anything else. oftentimes
because of the distorted way that we
have learned about human history in the
20th century. Most of us through
school, through media, movies,
television shows, fantasy books, etc.
We're we we're always taught that the
human being was first a very primitive
creature in a cave, right? And then
slowly he came out and he started making
little things and you know got a little
bit more advanced and because they
didn't understand how the universe
worked, they started to worship
everything at first. old humanity, they
used to worship the sun and the moon and
they worshiped the clouds and they
because they didn't had no idea what was
going on around them, right? And that
monotheism
so the worship of one god
namely in Judaism, Christianity and then
later and sealed by Islam that this only
came about and organized religion only
came about
after humanity had evolved to that. So,
we're taught that
what humanity began with is the worship
of many gods and that over time humanity
as they learned more and became more
logical they started to worship one god
and this is referred to as the evolution
of ideology.
However, this is exactly the opposite of
how it actually went. This is exactly
the opposite of what Allah teaches us in
the Quran, what the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam teaches us in the Sunnah.
Exactly the opposite.
Humanity began upon the fra began upon
pure knowledge
and devolved into polytheism and the
worship of other than Allah. Devolved
into immorality.
Didn't begin with immorality and then
evolved to become moral creatures. It's
the opposite. We began moral. We began
upon monotheism
and as time progressed,
human beings devolved into the worship
of idols and the worship of other than
Allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala.
And so
the way that things occurred is that
Abbas tells us ink
that the people were upon the of Allah.
Allah tells us this in the Quran
that people were upon one religion the
worship of Allah alone without any
partners.
And then what happened?
Abbas said, "As evil started to spread
amongst people
and as it became more common place and
as people started to be swayed and
inclined to their sins more,
there started to be fewer and fewer good
men to remind them of Allah, to command
them good and forbid them evil."
And so these few men
were regarded. You got to realize that
this time, this point, people still
respected
Islam. They still respected the worship
of Allah. They still looked up to people
who were righteous people.
However, they themselves were not
righteous. They were very sinful people,
but they respected those who chose to be
righteous. This is the beginning
of the end when people begin to go off
the path
together as as society. They respect
religion, but they don't do it
themselves. They respect the religious,
but they themselves are sinful.
And so these few good men started to die
off.
And Iban Abbas said that a shan
came to the people and said when these
men die off
who's going to remind you of Allah
you're going to start to forget when
these men they're gone. Who's going to
remind you of the good things they used
to remind you of and
warn you away from the bad things
that they warned you of? However, here's
a good idea.
Every time one of these good men passes
away,
you should construct a statue that looks
them
and put that statue wherever it is that
they were or over their graves.
So that when you pass by, this was the
idea. When you pass by, you see and you
remember, oh that is so and so. I
remember when he would tell me this and
tell us this and tell us that as a
reminder, as a keepsake,
as a an homage to this person's legacy.
And so they did that. They started to
make statues that looked just the
person sitting how they used to sit
dressed as they used to dress and they
would put it in various places
throughout their town. Then what
happened is as it goes generation after
generation the tales of these men were
replaced by other tales
and the later generations
no longer remembered
why these statues were built.
All they know is that their forefathers
built these statues. But they don't know
why or who these statues are supposed to
depict.
And then a shaan came back
and he told them these statues
were built by your forefathers to
represent your gods that you are
supposed to worship.
These men were special men
that would intercede on your behalf with
Allah.
So you go to the statue and you worship
these men and they in turn will
intercede on your behalf with Allah. And
this is when idolatry
spread and was its first laid its first
stain on the history of humanity. This
is when idolatry began.
And this is when
was sent to humanity. This is when they
first needed a messenger because they
had lost all u they had lost all
remnants of the worship of Allah alone
without any partners. And so we see from
this that a shan takes us astray
individually.
However, his endgame for societies
spread far into the future. They are not
just for today. He will plan for decades
ahead of time, hundreds of years ahead
of time.
You know, , and we'll end with this.
Just back in the 50s and 60s here in
America,
it was against the law
that Elvis Presley on TV be shown from
the hips down. That was against the law.
Illegal. You know why? Because the moves
that he did with his hips were
considered to be way too vulgar for the
American public.
If we look at that today, we say, "I
can't imagine that this is vulgar at
all." Yeah. Because we are so enveloped
in vulgarity that this looks innocent.
This looks good today.
He and those him are the ones that
took the first step for society to reach
and devolve in the debauchery that they
are engaged in today. All of this zena
that you see around you, it was
pioneered by men that who did just
a little something different with their
hips, just a little something different
with their clothes, just a little
something different with the movie
because a shan takes societies astray
one decade at a time. No,
decades at a time, maybe even centuries
at a time. And it can always be rooted
back to that first step off of the path
of Allah. We ask Allah subhanahu
wa'ta'ala that he guide us, teach us and
that he subhanahala
grant us the enlightenment to be able to
distinguish truth when we hear it from
falsehood. The courage to adhere to that
truth, the honor of dying for and upon
it and the cou and the nobility of being
resurrected upon that truth and with its
people.